Welcome to the first live
taping of the recent interview
podcast.
I am your host, Nick Gillespie.
Thank you for being here.
And our our guest
tonight is one of the most
provocative, thoughtful, heterodox,
courageous writers at work today
and this is her fourth glass of
wine, so hopefully she's also
one of the drunks.
She is certainly probably
the only writer living dead
or who will ever be conceived or
created in a laboratory who
has been compared both to Norman
Mailer and Roseanne Barr.
Laura Kipnis is
the author of a shelf full of books
including Ecstasy, Unlimited Against
Love, Unwanted Advances
and the main subject of tonight's
conversation.
Love in a Time.
Love in the Time of Contagion.
She taught film and journalism at
Northwestern and a number of other
places, and she's been published
everywhere The New York Times,
Harper's The Atlantic Slate,
and Even Reason.
Despite being a lapsed Marxist
feminist, by her own admission,
what's always made her work stand
out to me and I think I
this is a widely shared
appreciation, is an attention
to the telling detail and a pursuit
of the truth even and especially
when it upsets settled ideological
doctrine and dogma, and
an intellectual and emotional
curiosity that pulls the reader
into the dark forest of sexuality,
gender and longing.
Maybe most importantly, for the
current moment, she's also a
champion of free speech and free
expression in a world that seems
kind of upset with that.
So, Laura Kipnis,
thanks for talking to RESA.
Thank you.
Was you? You pull out a little bit
of her.
Thank you, Nick.
Thank you, everyone.
So, Laura, tell
Start, what's the
elevator pitch for love in the time
of contagion?
And what do you what do you hope
people walk away from the book
thinking?
Well, so I
had written this book Against Love,
a polemic a couple of decades
ago, which was this kind of anti
domestic tract
about the prison and premature.
Is this sort of echoing Tell me if,
yeah, no, it's OK.
It's about like premature
cemetery of domestic couple Tomb
Coupledom and then found myself
ensconced in domestic coupledom
during the lockdown.
So is the greater pickup line up.
You put it out on the street and
somebody picked it up?
Yes, something like that.
Yeah. I mean, you know, somebody
wanted.
They were going to make you
part of domestic bliss.
Something like that happen.
It's true.
But I mean, I'm also very interested
in the ways that like as a lapsed
Marxist feminist or possibly
residual or something.
I mean, you know, I quote Marx
in the book in the sense that we
don't get to make history under
circumstances that we choose.
And I say the same thing about love,
you know, we don't get to love under
the circumstances we choose, you
know, we're loving in historical
time and contending with
all the things that are dumped on US
historical forces and
this virus, you know, which was in
a lot of ways, an historical force
as well.
So in the same way that it sort
of held this microscope up to
the country and exposed all of the
inequities and exposed all these
things that were sort of there all
along that nobody wanted to look at.
I think it did the same thing for
love and our love lives.
So I talk about my own situation
in some detail and
also talked to other people
about what they were dealing with.
And you know what,
what people learned and
didn't learn and discovered
and exposed and all of that.
You know, one of the things that I
like about the book and your writing
in general, too, is that it is
personal.
And I don't know if it's
maybe it's confessional, but it's
never exhibitionist
or narcissistic.
So I don't know how you do that,
but you talk about things in
a way that is just
revelatory rather than
kind of like, Why am I reading this?
Thank you.
Early on in the book, you talk about
how in passing
kind of talk about how COVID
is, you know,
it echoes AIDS,
not in
in various ways.
And do you think or and
you say you wonder whether or not
COVID will have the same kind of
long tail effect on
everything that AIDS had?
What is the what's the crux
of the impact of AIDS, do you
think? And you know, have you
since writing the book, have you
figured out like, yeah, COVID is
actually going to be haunting us for
a long time? Or maybe not.